smoke from wildfires in Canada are
affecting tens of millions of Americans
in parts of the eastern U.S New York
City had the worst air quality of any
major city on earth yesterday as a dense
Haze obscured the city skyscrapers the
smoke stretched all the way down to the
Carolinas and is expected to get worse
today meteorologist Stephanie Abram from
our partners at the weather channel is
tracking all of this Stephanie good
morning so how long could this last
May good morning unfortunately it could
last for a while there are fires burning
all across Canada with over 9.3 million
Acres charred and for some perspective
one acre is about the size of a football
field without the end zones smoke from
these fires will continue to cause poor
air quality here in the U.S from the
Midwest to the Northeast and even into
the South there's going to be thick
smoke pollution at least through
Saturday especially into the Northeast
so anyone sensitive to air quality
should stay indoors and if you're
driving put your AC on recirculate and
if you do have to go outdoors in this
make sure you use an n95 or a p100
respirator we can actually Trace where
the smoke is originating from and for
New York today it's coming all the way
from northern Canada tomorrow we'll
still have bad air quality in the
Southeast with smoke traveling from
central Canada down into Charleston
South Carolina the same system helping
direct the smoke South will also keep
the Northeast 10 to 20 degrees below
average as we head over the next two
days for more in-depth coverage you can
watch weather channel on cable or live
on your favorite TV streaming devices
and Nate unfortunately government
officials in Canada are saying there's
an increased risk for wildfires through
August so that means we could see more
smoke here on the lower 48. all right so
keep your AC on recirculate and use a
mask if needed that's great advice
Stephanie Abrams you got it